I'm Bill Summers and a member of the
Terry Lector ship committee and it's my
pleasure to introduce uh this lecture
and to once again welcome you and our
lecture uh Professor David SLO Wilson to
Yale and to this lecture series uh just
a few procedural issues to remind you
after the lecture there will be a
question and answer period And if you
would come down to the microphones here
so that uh we all can hear the question
and they can be recorded for posterity
uh that would be good uh if you want to
continue the discussion online there's
an online discussion forum uh involving
Professor Wilson uh if you go to the uh
website at yale.edu
Terry lectures um you'll find a a link
to the online discussions uh after the
question and answer period uh we will
adjourn for reception and we would hope
you all could join us for
uh good food and some wine uh it's
across the street in the political
science department just across the the
parking lot
there and um so uh as you've heard in
the introductions to the previous
lectures Professor Wilson is a
distinguished professor in both
biological sciences and anthropology at
bingamon University and he's the author
of multiple Works dealing with
evolutionary biology and societal
structure and function I think it's fair
to say that most recent work Darwin's
Cathedral completely captivated our
committee representing as it does the
precise interplay between science and
religion uh as elaborated in the aims of
the Terry lecture series uh in his first
three lectures Professor Wilson laid the
groundwork for his explication of a
thoroughly current view of the
principles of evolutionary biology
including the very fra concept of uh the
unit of darwinian selection I for one is
a molecular biologist uh watching from
the sidelines of this debate for over 30
years now um think I finally obtained a
clear understanding uh of this
generation long controversy and I find
Professor Wilson's analysis quite
convincing also he has prepared Us by
showing how the features of social
organization embodied in all
religions as represented by a
statistically sampled set of religions
from his last lecture can be tested for
their fit to several alternative models
uh that he has presented today he will
conclude his Terry lecture series with
his discussion of Applied evolutionary
theory Professor
Wilson well you have a little preview of
my slides
here
um okay well thank you uh once again for
this great privilege of of uh giving the
terot
lectures um I began uh of course the the
title of this whole uh Series has been
Evolution for everyone and um in the
first lecture I uh tried to show how how
we can achieve a sociological
breakthrough um and um and get Evolution
um generally accepted in a sizable
population by presenting it as
unthreatening explanatory and useful
today I want to concentrate on the
useful part I'm going to try to show how
adaptationist thinking which is the
center piece of evolutionary theory uh
can be used to solve uh address
practical problems then I want to
discuss what I call environmental
intervention so often uh what's what's
threatening about evolution is the idea
of determinism that uh we're going to
determined by our genes to uh behave a
certain way and that this creates a an
incapacity for um um human potential and
I want to argue against that by showing
that evolutionary thinking leads to a
very interesting kind of uh and
effective kind of environmental
intervention and then I want to talk a
little bit about some of my own current
research on how to study
prosociality uh not just in the in the
religious context but uh in everyday
life and this uh talk is going to be a
little bit like skydiving we're going to
plumet through a large number of
subjects very quickly and then we're
going to um uh open the parachute and
drift more leisurely through uh through
the final uh subject matter and what
makes this comprehensible I would like
to say is this idea of extreme
integration that that although we're
going to be passing through many
subjects quickly it's the same way of
thinking uh this one conceptual
framework which is being applied to all
of these different subjects and that's
exactly why it is that um that Evolution
can become a general way of thinking for
um for everyone okay so let's jump right
off the plane into a single subject
which is pregnancy sickness uh my first
example of the utility of adaptation is
thinking a large fraction of women
experienc food aversion and nausea
during their first trimester of of
pregnancy and this is primarily been
regarded as a sickness by the medical
profession something that we'd want to
develop medicines to uh to be alleviated
uh but to the evolutionist uh there's
something um U strange here that
requires an explanation which is what
how is it that there can be something
which is costly to such a large fraction
of the population I mean an evolutionist
something's bad for you it tends to go
away so right away this Rings warning
Bells this is something that we want to
explain and there's more than one
possibility a point that I've been
making throughout these lectures from
the beginning is that any Theory does
not just automatically give you the a
single answer it gives you a number of
plausible Alternatives and then the
scientific method must take over in
order to sort among them so how can we
explain something that's costly and yet
uh remains at a high frequency in a
population um is it an infectious agents
or certainly diseases are are remain in
high frequency like the common cold in
this case that doesn't seem very
plausible uh could it be something like
an a modern environmental effect like a
toxin for example this is possible um
and then another possibility is that
when something is costly the reason it's
maintained is because there's some other
benefit associated with that cost so
could there be some hidden benefit
associated with the symptoms of
pregnancy sickness and when this
hypothesis has been developed
in the following way so here's the
hypothesis pregnancy sickness might be
an adaptation to protect the fetus from
food toxins so the rationale of this
hypothesis is as follows uh plants and
microbes have evolved toxins to avoid
being eaten consumers have evolved
counter defenses either to inactivate
these toxins or to tolerate them so
there's been a co-evolutionary race
between uh omnivores and herbivores and
the things that they eat uh but that the
embryo is more sensitive to toxins in
the adult organism especially during
early development so that what what
counts as food for the adult counts as
toxic for a developing embryo and if
these um assumptions are true then the
females would need to be adapted to
modify their eating habits when they
become pregnant so that would be the
adaptation and then the food aversions
in the nausea associated with with this
adaptation is what we know is what we
see as as pregnancy sickness now right
away once we formulate this hypothesis
testable predictions follow from this
from this general idea uh we want to
know what foods are most likely to cause
pregnancy sickness and we can make
predictions it is those foods which are
most likely to be um toxic to the
developing embryo that causes pregnancy
sickness we we could make predictions
about the timing of the food aversions
it takes place mostly when the when the
major organ systems are being laid down
we can look at the empirical literature
on the effects of ingested food on
miscarriages what kinds of foods cause
miscarriages and birth defects uh we can
look at the rates of miscarriages in
women who do and do not uh experience
pregnancy sickness we can make
predictions about cultural
cross-cultural variation certainly this
hypothesis includes humans but extends
Beyond humans so that we'd make a
prediction that other species would
experience something like pregnancy
sickness and would change their diets
during um uh during PR
and then we can begin to look for other
traits that are part of an adaptation to
avoid these toxins but but have never
been associated with pregnancy sickness
before so we might look for changes in
sensory physiology or liver metabolism
and then we have interesting phenomenon
such as eating clay which happens also
during pregnancy that we might be able
to to to integrate in with this
hypothesis because Clay is something
which absorbs toxins and uh and other
species do this uh too
so now what are the practical
consequences of this since I'm supposed
to be assess um addressing the utility
of um evolutionary theory well clearly
if pregnancy sickness is a negative side
effect of an adaptation to protect the
fetus it would be insane to try to
alleviate this with medication imagine
that you're driving around and and in
your car and all of a sudden the warning
light goes on check oil and you take it
into the shop and the mechanic uh goes
into the dashboard and removes the light
behind the cheze oil
uh uh icon and says all better so
clearly there can be no more important
distinction in medicine than between a a
sickness something which is damaging you
and a defense against a sickness we want
to know what it is that we're dealing
with and so if this hypothesis is
correct of course it's going to
completely change the way that we regard
this and uh the way that we regard this
illness now who is it that proposed this
hypothesis and where can you read about
it uh this hypothesis was first proposed
actually in the 1970s without much
attention and then it was revised by
revived in the 1990s by this woman named
Margie profet who went on to write a
book called pregnancy sickness using
your body's natural defenses to protect
your baby to be so she's anxious to
communicate this to a uh to a an
audience of mother of expecting mothers
and then the most recent scientific
review has been by um uh this man here
Paul Sherman and uh and um flaxman for
whom I could not find a photograph in
the journal quarterly review of of of
biology so here's what where you can
read about it but there's something very
remarkable about this topic and these
authors and this will this will going to
is going to replicate with almost every
subject that I present with you today so
who are these people and this
illustrates the theme I presented in my
first lecture on how it is that
evolutionary theory provides a kind of
an instant expert expertise what I call
Extreme integration that allows a person
to go from subject to subject and and
gain this kind of um instant expertise
because they have this single conceptual
framework that they're using so profet I
think was an undergraduate student when
she derived this hypothesis on the basis
of basic evolutionary principles without
any prior expertise in the subject uh
later she became the recipient of a
MacArthur genius award Sherman is one of
my colleagues he's an evolutionary
biologist at Cornell University uh and
he works primarily on ground squirrels
and naked mole rats so he has no special
expertise in medicine or or pregnancy
sickness and flaxman was an
undergraduate student who worked with
Sherman on the review article so what
did they have to bring to this and all
they had was this way of thinking in an
evolutionary sense so what they did was
they took this topic more or less went
through the logic that I went through
with you to explain you know why we
should be puzzled by this and the major
categories of explanation
and then they derived as I've shown you
a number of hypotheses which can be
tested empirically and there's a large
body of existing information in in the
literature which is what we can say
conceptually disorganized and
disorganized information is almost as
bad as no information at all all kinds
of information that's brought to bear on
this hypothesis but they have to gather
it together it is not assemble in any
way that can be done and this is an
enormous service and achievement and you
can make a lot of progress testing these
hypotheses before you do a single
experiment because there's just
snowdrifts of information that are out
there drifting around in a disorganized
form and then of course you have uh new
new research suggested so that this
serves as a guide for um future research
and and if you have a chance to read
especially the flexman and Sherman paper
I'd like you to read it not only for its
uh a specific subject matter a great
topic in its own right but also as a
model of this kind of way of doing
science basically of an evolutionary
perspective and then U the scientific
method testing these hypotheses I think
it's a really model paper to be read
from that standpoint and can be easily
read by um an undergraduate audience for
example well it wasn't long before Paul
Sherman struck again with another topic
and with another undergraduate student
Mr billing on darwinian Gastronomy why
weuse use spices here's another great
topic you know why is it that we that we
go to so much effort flavoring our food
as many possible hypotheses it could be
an arbitrary cultural kind of a thing
but the hypothesis that they developed
is that the spices have important
antimicrobial uh functions and they
proceeded to derive hypothesis and test
this one of the ingenious things they
did was use cookbooks as a as a
quantitative database from around the
around the world so they found data in a
way in a place that you wouldn't
necessarily expect it and repeated this
exercise basically for another topic
again a model of the scientific method
informed by evolutionary theory so here
are two specific topics but also the
general method that's being
employed and as for these two topics so
also for the more General subject of
darwinian medicine uh many books um
starting with why we get sick which goes
through this this kind of aist reasoning
and why it is needed in um medicine and
largely absent from medicine here's a
more recent book Evolution and health
and disease which is edited by the uh by
Steve Sterns the uh chairman of the EB
department at Yale and so this is a
whole burgeoning literature in which
this kind of reasoning and um and style
of doing science is is taking place for
subject after um after
subject okay so now let's take the same
uh reason reasoning and go on to another
subject domain uh social psychology uh
this is a good Exemplar of this Robert
kurban um who's at the University of
Pennsylvania here's a number of papers
by um barab and I want you to notice a
few things about these uh papers of
course I don't expect you to write them
down and I can provide these um at more
Leisure if if you uh email me but look
at the some of the titles of these
papers an experimental investigation of
cooperative types in human groups and
this focuses on individual differences
and why we might find individual
differences in cooperation and
exploitation something that which is a
very important subject from an
evolutionary perspective anxiety and
worldview defense of course a very
current topic Terror management that's
the modern context or coalitional
psychology that's the ancient context
how why are we responding to these
things as we are and is there some sense
in which we can it we we can place this
in a in a context of of of living in
groups and coalitions that are competing
against other coalitions because that
has been what's been taking place
through deep evolutionary time The
evolutionary origins of stigmatization
the functions of social exclusion and
then finally can race be erased
coalitional computation um and social
categorization and a common theme of his
work is that he takes a modern problem
such as ra
uh
categorization and and explains it in
terms of ancient
psychology another thing that you should
notice is that these are not marginal
journals that this kind of research by
Rob and uh and uh and his his colleagues
is being published in the very best
science and and uh and psychology uh
Journal so this is very much on the
Forefront of current uh of current
science now here's just an example from
his paper on stigmatization what is the
basic logic that he's following here and
how how simple is it so in social
psychology the subject of stigmatization
has been studied for a long long time
there's a big literature for all of
these subjects but it has been studied
as a single subject and as a single
subject is quite confusing it's hard to
derive
generalities so what kurban does is he
ask the question what are the important
would be the important contexts of
social exclusion in our ancestral
environment in the environment in which
our psychological aptitude were evolving
and he comes up with at least three
different ones that are plausible one is
Norm violations that if you break social
norms then there's a reason to exclude
you so that we might find a psychology
which is centered around Norm
violations then there's a psychology of
ingroup outgroup relationships if you're
not a member of my group it doesn't
matter whether you're violent a social
Norm I'm going to exclude you just
because you're not a member of my group
and so we have a separate logic for this
particular context and then if you're a
member of my group and you're a solid
citizen but you have a disease that's
another reason to exclude you and has
and which has a logic still different
from these first two contexts and so
what evolutionary thinking is the little
dash of evolutionary thinking gives you
is that this one topic confusing as
treated as a single topic begins to make
more sense when we subdivide it into
three topics context which makes sense
in terms terms of the What's called the
EA the environment of evolutionary
adaptedness and so kurban took the
existing literature and he interpreted
in these three ways and made and made
great sense of the literature so this is
a nice example of how uh a little bit of
evolutionary thinking can be used to
organize an existing
literature here's an example from my own
work um I just published a paper in the
current issue of human nature called
called cognitive cooperation when the
going gets tough think is a group so
here's the little dash of evolutionary
thinking that I
employed um of course a cooperation we
know we're a very Cooperative species
and that's cooperation has been
important in in human evolution and yet
cooperation is almost always studied in
the context of physical activities such
things as defense and and foraging and
things like that yet if you think about
it cognitive activities such as memory
decision making and perception also can
form the basis of cooperation so if we
merge our muscles and have merged our
muscles throughout our evolutionary
history then perhaps we've also merged
our minds and we can think of cognition
not just as something which is contained
within a single head but which is
something which takes place among a
whole group this is an idea which is has
been uh developed beautifully in the
social insects the idea of a social
insect is a single colony is a single
mind has been is not Science Fiction
it's been it's been explored in great
detail for social insects but for
humans what do we think with humans and
as with so many other subjects there's a
large large literature on group decision
making in humans group problem solving
hundreds of papers and when you read it
what you find is it's a lot of micro
theories basically separate research
programs but the information is very
disorganized from any kind of broad
coherent uh uh conceptual framework so
once again you apply the conceptual
framework you organize the existing
literature it it suggests new
experiments and in this case um this
really overturns received wisdom because
if you read the psychological literature
you get the very strong impression that
human groups are are not good
decision-making units that that that
being in a group actually interferes
with your mental functioning the
brainstorming literature is a great
example it was suggested by a
advertising executive in the 1950s that
people think much better and more
creatively in groups than alone and
psychologists were soon on to this
subject and doing very carefully
controlled experiments in which people
would either do things in groups or in
what's called nominal groups uh um um um
thinking independently and then you
would merge their answers and see do the
real groups do better than the nominal
groups and the answer is uniformly know
so that now psychologists have more or
less abandoned the idea that
brainstorming works and they've gone on
to see why is it that groups make
individuals wor group think became a
household word it's the idea that when
people when people think in groups they
become more dysfunctional and some of
the policy disasters um in um political
decision making is caused simply because
groups sort of group think took over and
and made people think worse so against
that background it's really interesting
to go back to First principles and to
ask what would we expect in terms of
cognitive cooperation are there
situations in which we can show that
group cognition works and that groups
think better than individuals and the
answer I think is very strongly yes so
we have a really a whole new ball game
in a sense I think that this is a a
wonderful uh topic to think
about okay now let me talk a little bit
about the idea of environmental um
intervention and what I mean by this is
that of course all species don't exist
in a single environment they exist in a
range of environments and all species
are flexible to a degree uh humans much
more than most and what this means is is
that you can think of of U of A of a
population is as having a set of if then
rules so there's a range of environments
in which
um they might be in ABC and d and for
each environment there's an Adaptive
Phoenix type which I've called a prime
through D Prime so this is often called
a norm of reaction if you put the
environments on the on the x- axis and
the phenotype on the Y AIS then you get
a a a curve of some sort and against
this background we can now say let's say
that for some reason we think that
phenotype B is a desirable phenotype we
want to promote it how are we going to
do it and the answer very simple is that
um if if if we're in environment a C and
D it's going to be real tough to produce
Behavior B Because Behavior B is
maladaptive in those environments we're
going to have to work against the nature
of the species basically in order to
produce the B but if we produce
environment B it'll be hard to get
anything other than b Prime so that if
we have a behavior that we want to
promote the best way to do that is to
provide the appropriate environment in
which that behavior is adaptive and as
strange as it might seem here we're
thinking as evolutionists but it's
bringing us to a policy in which we're
environmental interventionists that that
that our knowledge about Evolution
enables us to make a particular
environmental Intervention which we
might not have thought of otherwise okay
so that's the idea stated in abstract
terms and let's look at an example my
favorite one is the work of uh my
colleagues Martin margar Wilson and
Martin Daly to revolutionary
psychologist at mcm's University and
they have a lovely paper in the British
medical journal
on life expectancy economic inequality
homicide and reproductive timing in
Chicago neighborhoods and what they show
is that the Chicago neighborhoods are
quite demographically stable so they've
the same mix of people basically for uh
um a long time and the quality of life
varies greatly among these neighborhoods
which is reflected in life expectancy
that varies from mid-50s in the worst
neighborhoods to the mid 70s in the best
neighborhood
and they were able to get information on
reproductive demographics in women and
violent risk-taking behavior in men and
showed a beautiful very tight
relationship between these two uh
parameters and life expectancy it's a
very tight relationship the kind of
thing we wish for as and usually don't
achieve as social
scientists so these are socially
undesirable behaviors we want to get rid
of them teenage pregnancies and in uh in
our inner cities and so um how can they
be eliminated and why do they why do
they exist in the first place and it was
so telling that when you ask the women
in the uh these these uh um bad
neighborhoods why are you having
children so early they give an answer
with which you can only sympathize they
say I want my mother to see her
grandchildren and I want my mother to
help me raise my children I want to see
see my grandchildren and all around me
people are weathering that's the word
that they use people are
weathering so what this means is in a
sense and to put it in more biological
terms is that is that our species and
other species are flexible enough so
that they can calibrate their
reproductive schedule to their life
expectancy and if you make life so
chaotic and unstable so that there might
not be a future or that or that the
future is short then you're going to
calibrate your reproduction accordingly
and who wouldn't that's the Adaptive
thing to do it's a little bit more
difficult to sympathize with violence in
men but I think that if you understand
it and you and from the male perspective
the only way that you're going to
reproduce is to get some kind of status
during your short life and the only way
to do that is to take great risks then I
think that you could also sympathize
with this as a adaptive solution in men
and so the way that we can understand
this in terms of the previous graph is
that we have two environmental
situations one with lower life
expectancy high life expectancy and we
have this if then rule this adaptive if
then rule so the behaviors that we think
of as socially
undesirable when we think of them out of
context is actually adaptive in the
context that they occur so the if then
rule would be if your life expectancy is
low then reproduce early as women take
high risk as men and in general discount
the future and this is another thing
that you see an unstable uh social
environments if you give someone a
choice between a little bit now and a
lot in the future people take a little
bit now we see this with lotteries have
you ever wondered when someone wins a
lottery and they have a choice of taking
a lump sum now which is much smaller
than than than um the amount that's
offered um regularly over a lifetime so
many take that lump some they've
discounted the discounted the future and
so if you want to solve these problems
if you regard them as problems and want
to solve them there's a simple answer
increased life
expectancy and if you do that then you
won't be able to prevent individuals
from responding appropriately in that
situation so if you if this is the
behavior that you want there's the
environment that will produce it if if
if you keep this environment it will be
very very difficult to achieve this
Behavior so this is an idea this is the
concept of environmental
intervention this is a similar concept
every once in a while you uh come across
a study in the scientific literature
which is as profound and memorable as a
short story and uh this is one for me
this is an experiment in the literature
on machiavellianism which again gets a
differences between cooperation and
exploitation so you can give people a
test called the mock test and you uh can
identify so-called High mock individuals
who are quite willing to uh exploit
others and low mock individuals who we
can think of as more cooperative and
then you can take them in an experiment
and you can have them do a task with a
supervisor in which is possible to steal
small amounts of money and the
manipulation is is that the supervisor
either behaves in a way which is
trusting he makes it clear that he
expects the person's not going to cheat
he's not going to check them or anything
like that or suspicious he makes it
clear that he does expect them to cheat
and he's going to check now and then to
make sure that that they don't and the
result of this experiment is is that the
himo steal in both circumstances they
don't care whether they're being trusted
or not they just want the
money the lxs are very happy to
cooperate when they're interacting with
the trusting supervisor but when the
supervisor becomes suspicious the the
lch the cooperator interprets that as
itself a defection if he's not going to
cooperate with me if he's going to not
going to trust me well screw him and so
they steal even more than the himx in
that situation they do it openly and
they dare the supervisor to do something
about it this is a form of
retaliation and so this is really kind
of a bind I think this this is just a
kind of a little microcosm of life in
general what are you going to do what
kind of social environment are you going
to are you going to have you can't just
be trusting or you're going to be ripped
off by by the himx of the world and you
can't just be suspicious because then
everyone's going to defect what are you
going to do you have to have some kind
of environment which is trusting but
protected how are we going to have this
and if we don't then implement this kind
of uh sophisticated kind of social
grouping then we're going to have uh uh
dysfunctional behaviors here's another
um there's a whole huge literature on
this I was describing this to the uh
Divinity students last night many many
uh experiments in the um um
behavioral economics literature along
these lines so you take a group of
individuals you give everyone
$20 and they can keep as much as they
want or place as much as they want in a
central pot everything that's put in the
central pot is doubled and then
distributed equally to all members and
this is a classic social dilemma the
best thing for the group to do is for
everyone to put it in everyone gets
their money doubled but an individual
who puts nothing in when everyone else
puts it in then they get most of that
back and they do much better and in fact
at all points the best thing to do is to
keep your money and then profit from the
Cooperators so what happens in this kind
of U experiment when it's played by the
same members again and again uh at the
start the average member is moderately
generous a lot of people well-meaning
you put some money in uh but pretty soon
they realize that not everyone is doing
this and they get angry and in the
context of the experiment the only way
that they can express their anger is to
back out basically and and so the
Cooperators who are perfectly willing to
cooperate they become uncooperative and
at the end of 10 or so iterations of
this game nobody's cooperating
cooperator cooperation has gone down to
to zero
okay so now we change the game we have a
public good game with punishment it's
just like the old game except we put a
second pot and you have a choice you can
contribute to the first pot that gets
doubled and redistributed or you can put
in your money in a second pot and what
that is used for is to punish the
Slackers who don't contribute to the
first pot okay and in that situation not
everyone but a substantial fraction of
individuals love to contribute to that
punishment pot and so now and these are
called altruistic punishers because
there's been numerous experiments which
do this in ways which make it absolutely
clear that the Punisher is not going to
get his money back in any sense at all
that he's going to have a net loss loss
by doing this and they still do it so
they're actually willing to incur a cost
in order to act like police like this
and so what happens now is because
individuals who don't contribute to the
first plot are being punished it's in
everyone's interest to do this and
cooperation Rises to to um um near near
fixation what a perfect microcosm for
life I just think this is so interesting
and how could this not be relevant to to
situations outside of the laboratory and
so some a few real world applications a
wonderful paper by Sam BS and Herb Gus
who I've talked about several times this
was published in the Boston Review uh
1998 a nice title is equality P the
evolution of reciprocity in the future
of egalitarian politics this is a nice
article in part because it's followed by
commentaries by a number of authors
including myself from many different
disciplines and what they're saying is
is that
that that experiment is like the mic a
microcosm for the welfare system and why
is it that that uh people got pissed off
about the welfare system was that
because they'd become
ungenerous and their answer is no it's
not it's not that people don't want to U
uh contribute to these public goods they
just don't want to be ripped off and so
if the welfare system is such that that
it is perceived to be exploitable that's
like the first version of the experiment
people might want to give to it but
they're not going to if it's just
vulnerable to exploitation so what you
want is a system which is generous which
takes care of the common good but is not
exploitable and religions are like that
that's one of the things that I um uh
found discovered and and stressed in my
previous lecture how good are religions
at at fostering cooperation in a way
which is actually hard to exploit
religions are just bristling with social
control mechanisms that make it
difficult to to cheat and and you might
think that that means that you know
nobody's well-meaning in religions
that's one of the interesting things is
is that when you provide a strong social
organization like that that makes it
difficult to cheat then the Cooperators
can
relax and that you can actually give as
you would like to give and you can feel
safe so an environment like these kinds
of social controls far from serving as a
substitute for goodwi and altruism
actually provides an environment in
which Good Will can can FL flourish so
you have a positive relationship between
social control and the kind of
disposition which we would call
genuinely altruistic it's not a negative
relationship here's a couple more papers
by the prolific Swiss Economist Ernst
Fair um a very nice review paper in
nature uh called the nature of human
altruism and then more recently in
science fair has gone neurobiological
and he's now having people do these
kinds of experiments under the uh
functional uh um um M&R uh and getting
uh brain activity basically as people as
people do these uh um U tasks so we're
we're we're being theoretically we're
being we're being evolutionary and then
experimentally we're going everything
from behavioral down to the uh
neurobiological level and once again um
the top science and and uh and um social
science journals that this is being
published in there's nothing marginal
about this this kind of research has
already arrived is the point that I'm uh
trying to make okay well I'm doing
pretty well I'm going to put on my
parachute now and and I'm going to talk
a little bit about how can we use these
Concepts to study um prosociality in
everyday life and this is the research
that I'm currently engaged in um all of
this research it takes place in
laboratory experiments or in various
ways but what we really want to do is we
want to study people in their natural
environment as an as a biologist would
or as a a as an an anthropologist would
so first we need our conceptual
framework and we want to know what
causes some people to be pro-social to
be oriented to do things for the good of
others and others to be uh much less
pro-social and
U it's possible to derive four sets of
hypotheses I'm not going to go through
them in detail but I actually hope that
they can be that they'll sound familiar
on the basis of U of um the previous
lectures um one set of hypothesis
basically states that human populations
are multi- strategy communities this is
a fundamental outcome of of Game Theory
and in the context of cooperation and
exploitation you don't expect a single
type you expect differences there's
advantages of cooperation as long as you
as long as you're interacting with
fellow Cooperators and there's
advantages to exploiting cooperation and
what you end up with is the coexistence
of these types it's like a it's like an
inp specific Predator prey system and so
we should expect even in the fairest
social environment everyone everything
is benign not everyone's going to be
nice that's just a resource to be
exploited so you should always see
individual differences of the sort that
you would expect between species with a
predator prey interaction but that's not
the whole story because as we've seen
with some of these uh experiments if
you're in a social environment which is
not favorable to
cooperation where you're good will even
though you'd like to be a cooperator but
it's going to be exploited and many
people are very capable of turning off
their um their cooperation and
themselves becoming negative towards the
system which is not promoting
cooperation so when we see low
prosociality we don't necessarily uh um
attribute that to an individual although
it could be we could attribute it to the
social environment which makes proc
sociality difficult to to be successful
so uh we need to evaluate social
environments for pro-sociality in
addition to
individuals then there's another set of
hypothesis having to do with stress
clearly if I don't make much money I
cannot give much money to charity even
if I want to and so to some extent the
degree to which you first of all you to
be prosocial first of all you need to
want to be Pro social you need to be
inclined after that you need to have
some resources in order to give to
others and that's true for financial
resources it's also true for personal
resources so if I'm stressed out in my
own life it's going to be very difficult
for me to give to others in any sense so
we should expect to see a an um positive
relationship between stress and um lack
of prosociality on the other hand it's
when I'm stressed that I need help the
most and so there's the capacity to give
and there's also the need for help that
sort of cross Crosscut each other so
there's a complex relationship between
stress and prosociality that we can
predict and then finally there's belief
systems and this is so important
obviously when we talk about religion
but also otherwise is that really what
people have is a belief system that lies
between them and what they do you're not
interacting just directly with the real
world you're interacting with the real
real world through that's been filtered
through a belief system and so very
often then whether you're or not you're
pro-social might not be a function so
much as the environment that you're in
but the set of beliefs that you have and
and when we talk about belief systems it
has to be religions plus more everyone
has a belief system and so what is the
relationship between belief systems and
prosociality so we have a pretty rich
conceptual framework for organizing the
literature or for doing research and uh
so but now we need some good data where
are we going to get some some data to uh
test hypothesis on and for that I turn
to this wonderful man here with the
unpronouncable name of male chmi that's
a Hungarian name he's a very famous
psychologist most famous for his work on
what he calls flow which is the peak
psychological experience that we have
when we're so engrossed in what we love
to do if you're an athlete it's when
you're in the zone and if you're a
scholar it's when you're just lost in
your work and he likes to study that
psychological state but he's done many
many other studies and the method that
he uses is called The Experience
sampling method and this is a
wonderfully straightforward method in
which he outfits people with uh beepers
pagers which are programmed to Signal
them at random times during the day so
at every the day is divided into
two-hour blocks and during every block
you are beeped once during that block at
random at which point you pull out a
little questionnaire and you record
where you are what you're doing who
you're with and checklist of your
cognitive and emotional experiences what
you're thinking what you're feeling and
so on and so this is like an invisible
Observer perched on your shoulder that's
taking a snapshot of your experience at
random times during the day and if
you're a biologist or a naturalist what
could be better than having this kind of
information so mahale has done this at a
massive scale and I've started a
collaboration with him so that I can
take this data and I can retrofit it and
study evolutionary questions including
the EV the evolution uh the uh
prosociality and the particular study
that we're working with just to show you
the scale of this this was a study that
was um funded by the Sloan foundation
with the very practical purpose of
finding out how young people prepare
themselves for the workforce okay and so
it was conducted at 12 geographical
locations at 33 High School tools that
involved getting background information
on over 5,000 students and that includes
over 400 questionnaire items that was uh
asked on a one-time basis and then over
a thousand of these students performed
this beeper study for a week three times
space two years apart so that you have
longitudinal data for individuals in
addition to uh these onewe sampling
periods and so this was a huge project
maintained on a a computer database and
by making friends with mahaley I got the
whole thing on a CD in the mail for me
to uh play with and to ask evolutionary
uh questions and so with this
information especially these one-time
questionnaire items it's possible to
retrospectively make a pro-sociality
scale involving such questions as they
were asked as how important is having
strong friendships to you and your life
how important is helping other people in
your community and in your life how
important is working to correct s IAL
inequalities and so on there's 17 of
these questions which we can
retrospectively construct into a
prosociality scale very ingenious
methods uh by the way for validating a
scale such as uh such as this just to
indicate how neat this is um imagine
you're taking a math test and there's
some questions that are easy and some
questions that are hard okay some
arithmetic questions and some calculus
questions well everyone's going to
answer the easy ones right and only a
few people are going to answer the hard
ones right so there's an asymmetry there
okay so if there if a test is if a
questionnaire is addressing a single
thing it should be able to arrange the
questions in an easy to hard Continuum
in which everyone answers the easy ones
and fewer and fewer answer the hard ones
that's in contrast if a questionnaire
measures two things in which some people
would answer one and the other you get a
symmetry there some people would be good
at one and not the others and so you can
test you can validate a questionnaire
like this and see if it has this kind of
asymmetry or there's some sort of
no-brainer prosociality questions which
everyone with an ounce of prosociality
would answer and then some harder ones
so you get a winwing out process and so
this prosociality scale passes that test
so we can actually uh feel pretty good
about this as some kind of measurement
in a context independent way of
prosociality and here's the distribution
of scores it's unimodal so we get some
uh we get some real saints up here we
get some uh real questionable people
down here and then and then we get the
average citizen um
here okay so how do we explain now some
of the variation in this uh prosociality
you can do a standard kind of a multiple
regression analysis using other
questions in this big database and uh
turns out you can explain about 40% of
the variants which is pretty good with
14 items and here are the kind of things
which are predictive of pro-sociality
they're quite straightforward but also
quite interesting
you're more Pro pro-social if you live
in a supportive social environment so
the questions which ask how many
teachers care about you so there's a
school component if you're in a
neighborhood where if you're in a
problem you have neighbors who will help
if you're in a family that avoids
hurting feelings and then two religious
variables so religion emerges as an
important contributor to
prosociality these are the kind of
environmental factors which will which
statistically correlate with Pro
sociality then there's a bunch that
involve long range planning so if you
spend time on your homework out of
school if you think it's important to
have children if you don't think that
it's important to party and get wild if
you think you want to give your own kids
opportunities and that you expect to
encounter obstacles in other words if
you're if you have a long time Horizon
you also have a a large social Horizon
you're more likely to be pro-social and
that to me is very interesting and not
so obvious basically why isn't it
possible for there to be an impulsive
pro-social person and of course there
might be but the statistical trend is is
that the longer you're planning for the
future then the more Cooperative the
more prosocial that you are and then we
have some optimism and self-esteem
variables that if the better you feel
about yourself basically the more
pro-social you are although we'll see
that we're about to see that there's
some exceptions to that uh to that rule
so this is a good first step as some of
the factors that per predict
prosociality in everyday life but we can
make some more interesting predictions
and one is that there are more ways to
be bad than good Leo Tolstoy said uh
it's the first line of Anna Carina all
happy families are alike each unhappy
family is unhappy in its own way that's
said to be the most famous first line in
in literature and what this means is is
that in order to be highly pro-social it
requires a happy combination
of um Events first you need to have the
disposition then you need to have the
personal means then you need to be in an
environment in which it's possible in
which it's it possible to be pro-social
and if any of these three things are
absence then you're going to become less
pro-social so what that means is is that
if we take this distribution and if we
look at the high end the high prosocials
and the low end we can make a
predictions that the Low Pro social
individuals should be more variable
because any of these things go wrong and
you become less pro-social so we can
make a testable prediction that these
individuals here at the low end of the
distribution if we look at the variation
in their responses to some of these
one-time questionnaire items the
variance should be higher than these
high PE individuals who have to have
everything right in order to be u in
order to be high prosocial and so when
we test this prediction on these many
items which for for which it's available
which we can categorize items which
indicate self-esteem emotional emptiness
uh long-term goals efficacy trust
deviant stress in all of these cases
these items it does turn out that in um
many more than half that there the
variation in the low prosocials is
greater than in the high
prosocials with one exception there's
seven religious variables and those are
more variable in the high prosocials and
the low prosocials so what does that
mean we're talking about variation
remember so what that means is is that
if you're lower in prosociality you're
probably not very
religious if you're in high prosociality
you might be religious or you might not
be you might be a a nice atheist like me
I'm not religious at all I'm highly
prosocial and so all of the religious
variables are
more VAR variable for the high
prosocials than for the low prosocials
and we can do better
we're not saying that the Low Pro
socials are variable in every single
respect we're saying that they're
variable for the when it comes to the
things that are most relevant to
prosociality so you can take it's a
little complicated to explain but you
can take these single questions
basically and you can test their
relevance how well they correlate as
single variables to pro-sociality that's
how relevant they are to prosociality on
the xaxis that's they're r squared as
single factors and then the more
relevant to Pro sociality the more this
discrepancy and variability between high
prosocials and low prosocials is okay so
this is a very nice thing that we've
found now we can make another prediction
and as you look at the low prosocials
here they are they're they don't have
religion they're they they live in a
crummy social environment they have low
self-esteem they're they're not planning
for their future they really seem like
uh kind of decrepit individuals and yet
that doesn't fit the image of the high
MAAC the social Predator the individual
that's you know really might feel great
about themselves they're just out for
themselves you know why aren't there
lawyers who are basically planning for
their long-term Futures feel great about
themselves they're just out for number
one are these in this sample and what
would we what we would predict is that
there's different ways to achieve Low
Pro Association it you can be low proo
as a successful strategy in which case
your self-esteem should be just
great or you can be low low prosocial
because you live in such a harsh social
environment that it just not possible
for anyone to be pro-social and so you
can take this low prosocial group that
taale of the distribution and you can do
a cluster analysis and you're clustering
on the basis of items which are
basically on self-esteem these are
things which in the general sample
characterize High prosocials okay
in the whole sample high prosocials will
score high on feeling good about
themselves person of worth and so on and
what we're doing is a cluster analysis
just on the low prosocials and the
cluster analysis clearly divides the low
prosocials into very very different
groups so there's different ways to be
low pro-social and this group these are
the ones that feel great about
themselves okay these are the ones which
you might identify as as the um as the
ones who are actually pursuing an
exploit an exploitative social strategy
it turns out that these uh these uh High
self-esteem Low Pro socials are four F
males 80% of them are
males so we don't can't just talk about
high and low prosociality the theory
suggests and the data shows that that
human populations are a multi strategy
community and there's more than one way
to be pro-social there's different types
of low pro-social
individuals and we can do the same thing
with the high prosocials we can ask you
can we can use the religious variables
to do a cluster analysis and we get a
cluster of individuals who are high
prosocial and they're very much
religiously involved and then another
cluster high prosocial but not for
religious
reasons what about them we want to know
about differences between them they must
be motivated by very different sets of
beliefs
well it's been a real pleasure to
uh be able to present this information
in four lectures to such a distinguished
uh audience uh that's still just a small
fraction of the time that I have with my
class um and so I leave you with uh uh
one of the U Anonymous student
evaluations from my class which says uh
uh this course has changed the way I
look at things in general I try to see
them and understand them from an
evolutionary perspective now in my mere
four lectures I hope I've given you a
glimpse of this very
exciting things that are happening
across all subjects which I think um I
honestly think that what's happening
right now is as exciting as the early
days of evolutionary theory so thank you
very
much
I was thinking that uh looking at
uh sexual beliefs and aversions is one
way to get a handle on this for me um
and there's an obvious correlation
between um let's say um High INF from
morality low low um life expectancy and
intolerance toward any kind of sexuality
that doesn't produce children okay so
for example in the early Old Testament
um you know you you homosexuality sex
with children um you know U masturbation
um anything that doesn't result in a
likely pregnancy and and that's gotten
built into us that that that we have we
feel an aversion toward the other
orientation we feel aversion toward any
sort of sex it doesn't Pro e even um
Elder to Elder sex until we get there
and
um so so here we are so here we are in
an environment with uh low INF mortality
and higher life expect expectancy and
now we're passing laws and trying to
pass laws to to change the sexual laws
and practices uh in the interest of
Tolerance um and we're getting
resistance from the quarters that still
have the U other
circumstances um
so so one one possibility here is that
if everybody got this right
then they could say okay well I see this
this works in my environment but it
doesn't it's not God's law for every
environment right even though the pope
has already ruled infallibly on on
certain aspects of this um the other the
other thought is
that these aversions that seem to be
built into us have developed over
eons and they
they work more than they don't work in
other words if Things Fall Apart
tomorrow you know the the dollar goes to
hell and we go and spin into a long-term
Global depression Dark Age or whatever
then the tolerance attitudes suddenly
are not as adaptive as the intolerant
attitudes so so maybe the you know so so
we who are advocating the tolerance are
kind of assuming that the prosperity
will continue and and proliferate
whereas the people on the other end are
kind of maybe acting out will May that
may not continue so let's hold on to the
things that have worked over the long
term so comment well you you've
identified a great
topic and one which richly deserves to
be studied and really has not been
studied from this particular perspective
but but from what I know about uh
um
Christianity and the environment in
which it took place then something like
what you're talking about makes a great
deal of sense which is that Roman
society I I was astonished to discover
this was not replacing itself
demographically and you had you had
among other things huge female
infanticide and female infanticide is
another uh adaptation which makes sense
in a certain context of war in groups in
which it's really important to have
males basically to expand the group and
in that situation if you practice female
infanticide you bu you build up your
sons and then the Suns can raid for
women you can get females from the
outside makes great sense except when
everyone's doing
it truly and so there's time lags and
there stasis and there's things which
are adaptive and then they lead to and
then they cause changes in the
environment everything becomes uh uh we
got a a mismatch and and evolution is
not just so Nimble that it automatically
corrects things so we we have what what
could be a demographically pathological
situation in Roman society which was not
replacing itself in part because of
practices including sexual practices
homosexuality
non-reproductive um uh heterosexual
practices and against that background a
a a new religious sect which says none
of that and then prescribes sexual
practices only when it leads to
reproduction and that could actually
have been one of the contributing
factors to the increase of early
Christianity and which has been proposed
by um numerous people including Rodney
Stark that it wasn't just expanding by
conversion it was expanding by just
birth and death processes including its
respectful attitude towards women
Christianity was a great deal for
women in the early history of the church
and didn't become patriarchal until
until somewhat later as I understand it
now you fast forward to the present to a
case where things are demograph and so
the liberalization of sexual mors is
something which could well be for these
reasons and but the fact that there's
conflict and that
there's groups which resist this I don't
know whether to attribute that to an
Adaptive scenario or just the kind of
time lags and the and the basically the
inflexibility religions are Nimble and
flexible in some ways but in other ways
of course they're very very conservative
and they're unable to change as
institutions and typically what happens
is is that some other institution
changes so it might be a new religious
well a new um denomination or that's
more accepting will then will then grow
but the old ones won't necessarily
change so but you've raised a wonderful
topic and one which I think that if
anyone were to approach that seriously
would have a great time and would
probably show some very interesting uh
very interesting
things
I'll exercise My Prerogative and ask a
question as a followup to that uh the
The simple-minded evolutionary argument
would say that these non-reproductive
behaviors because they exist now the
sociobiologists would say they exist
because they're selected for there's
some hidden benefit to this
non-reproductive behavior is this a
rational position to take that is
non-breeders homosexuals who don't have
children why shouldn't they be just you
know eliminated is a unsuccessful
reproductive strategy this always comes
up of course in my uh in my classes and
and um you had that you had that one
ringer in the C well it actually came up
on the website also so this is discussed
a little bit on the on the uh website
and just a couple quick things to say
about it point one homosexuality is
actually quite common in nature in
non-human species point two sex can
often is used for non-reproductive
functions it becomes a kind of a social
currency and so uh point three um when
you look cross-culturally at
homosexuality you see often it's very
common but not
exclusive and of course it's much easier
to explain when it's not exclusive and I
think that that U um one reason why
homosexuality is is so it seems to be
exclusive in this culture is because
it's so prohibited that if you're going
to be it at all is it's all you can be
so we have numerous kinds of of um of
and that's the kind of resources that we
have to to explain it you konos are
closest relatives and the homosexuality
is amazing and in part female
homosexuality as a way of Performing
alliances that help female collectively
uh prevent dominance by
males it wouldn't surprise me at all if
you saw ma modern manifestations of
female homosexuality and be exactly the
same
reason culturally so it's it's a good
topic but one in which I think that when
you start to think about it in this way
you have have quite a few interesting
hypotheses and that initial puzzle that
makes everyone think of it you know how
can someone this is part of the kind of
the implicit Assumption of genetic
influence basically that if we see
homosexual it's there's a gene for
homosexuality and it's etc etc and so
the full story is is is very interesting
to to again to think
about you got to come down and that puts
you second compared to this guy
as a as a child of the second world war
I've uh always been interested in how we
came to win it and uh from my reading uh
I'm so impressed with um the contrast
between uh Hitler's uh dominating
singular
Authority and the uh and the uh
cognitive
cooperation uh that you got between uh
um Roosevelt and Churchill and the way
that Eisenhower had to put up with the
pattern on Montgomery isn't that a
wonderful field of study for your
topic it is and a point that I haven't
made but I have an essay called
evolutionary social constructivism I one
of the tragedies of modern scholarship
is the polarization in which those most
interested and most qualified with the
most detailed knowledge about culture
are the most skeptical and antagonistic
towards uh Evolution and it's
symmetrical those that are most
interested in evolution are the most
clueless about about cultural processes
and so there's a middle ground which is
just aching to be explored and my ESS my
essay is sort of a way to invite people
to explore this this middle ground and
uh just to pick up on on um um World War
II there's uh very nice paper by my
colleagues Pete Richardson and Rob Boyd
examining the social organization of
military units comparing Germany um
America Russia and then modern Israeli
military organizations and showing that
this makes a difference in terms of
fighting strength and the Germans came
out very well man for man the Germans
were about you know
1.2 units better than Americans and the
Russians just were hard
so but you have to ask why how can we
trace this to social organization that's
what I do with religion and you can also
do it with military organizations well
of course the fighting strength of
military groups is just a small part of
a war so at a larger scale then we can
ask the qu kinds of questions that
you're uh that you're asking so um I
just highly recommend this there's work
done on the Civil War for example why is
it that the north was so much more
vigorous than the South economically was
that just climate or was it the cultures
that that colonized those two regions
huge cultural differences in the
colonization patterns of the of the uh
new new world which could have by that
time built up differences that could
make that could make the difference so
there's so many cases in which we can
look at these ongoing I've tried to make
the point when you think of evolution
you think we're talking about the Stone
Age no this is so contemporary and you
can really think of it in terms of
modern I mean current social
organization
democratization for example how is it
how is it possible to get a given
culture to what we idealize as a modern
democracy that can be so difficult based
on the Deep structure of the various
Human Social organizations that exist
right now so this kind of study of
culture in relation to these
evolutionary Concepts is so badly needed
and it is such a vacant area I like to
say that culture might be the most
important subject if you were to do it a
ratio of the importance of a subject
divided by the degree that we understand
it that number would be bigger for
culture than U almost any other any
other
subject my question is um to what extent
do you feel that um this this social
Evolution this evolutionary process um
really is is hinged upon biological
mechanisms
uh in particular um you know the U the
basic uh fight flight sex food drives
that pretty much are in in every
organism um and what's your what's your
opinion as far as the linkage between
these basic biological neurobiological
mechanisms and what we see in terms of
um especially human behaviors trying to
socialize um I'm No Authority there's
probably people in this audience that
are better authorities than I but the
simple answer I think is that um
um the core of the human mind is like
all other animal minds and it's going to
have these very very deep uh emotional
circuits which are at the base of
everything a wonderful book I just
recently read was called effective
Neuroscience by Yak panp which makes
this point very nicely and from an
evolutionary perspective but then we
have this cognitive part of our brain
which is more or less unique to us in
which we can do very highly integrative
things um um and gives the
open-endedness that we know exists in in
our um in our species but when I look at
modern cultures and how they're
evaluated including in the normative
sense of the kind of cultures that
people strive for what I see is that
there's always just in a core sense
highly biological what do people want
they want to thrive in a sense you know
they want to be safe they want to be a
they want to have food on the table they
want to be free from persecution and and
so um I seldom see a big mismatch
basically between uh between what
culture seems to U strive towards and
basic biological uh uh
Goods thank you for such a clear
presentation in terms of your last point
it's hard to know what's caus and what's
correl ated because if people
biologically want that why haven't they
created the kind of social organizations
that maximize that and the question is
that if in fact as your data shows in
order to have that you have to have a
supporting social environment that does
that then why are we dealing with things
like the four the car I mean in the
Sudan and worries about genocide and in
fact the 60th commemoration ation of the
liberation of the death camps in um in
um under the Nazis so I think that
everything can be traced back to biology
but isn't there an element of things
that are choice that may or may not be
biological but have other uh variables
or other
causes well I like I I I feel that the
last thing that you said needs to be
separated from the first thing that you
said as to whether there's choice and so
on yes I think that everything that we
associate with human intentionality and
Free Will and so on um it is not to be
taken away but and still can be rooted
in an evolutionary explanation and uh
Dan dennett's book Freedom evolves uh
amongst others as a um as an account
basically of how the concept of Free
Will can be um uh approached from an
evolutionary um perspective
but the first point that that you made
to me if I were to say a single thing
about it it reiterates the fundamental
problem of social life which was also at
the center of my all of my lectures
which is you I mean it's extraordinary
to me that if you go back 15,000 years
the largest Cooperative human group that
you would have found would have been
several hundred
people and it is adaptation at the group
level groups getting along
is not automatic in evolution it took a
miracle of social genetic social
engineering in order to get groups of
hunter gatherers to cooperate and then
tribes to cooperate and then cultural
Evolution has been taking place ever
since it's been expanding that
Cooperative
Circle to some extent now we have groups
of millions of people that are
cooperating sort of and then all kinds
of
conflicts all of this has to be
explained in terms of this messy process
of multi-level selection but that
question why do we see such Strife In
This World At Large scales and why do we
see such carelessness about for example
our environment over long temporal
scales why can we not do anything about
global warming these are precisely the
questions which evolution is least
equipped to handle unless we can invent
cultural mechanisms basically to expand
that social Horizon and that temporal
Horizon
um um better and intentional thought and
Free Will the the higher cognitive human
functions are pro are going to be really
important in order to do that because
it's probably not going to take place
fast enough by a blind process of
cultural Evolution so I think what
you're reaching for when you talk about
Free Will and so on is not at all
opposed to this I think ultimately if we
had a longer conversation we would end
up
agreeing
there are no more questions I want to
thank all of you thank our speaker Davis
l Wilson thank you for being here at
these lectures uh I think they've been
excellent lectures it's very hard for
the terric to find topics and people can
address of the science and on one side
religion or values on the other I think
these lectures have done an excellent
job of that and I appreciate our speaker
for that and for you being here and now
uh Provost Andrew Hamilton proost of
university is here uh to present a small
presentation to our speaker
please thank you Dale and normally this
is a job that would have been done by
President Levin who is currently in
Davos at the world economic Forum with
uh many people who I suspect we all hope
will be practicing adaptive Behavior as
they as they discuss the problems of of
the world and it's a particular pleasure
on behalf of President Levan and and on
behalf of the entire Yale Community
particularly the biological community of
which I'm part as well to thank you
Professor Wilson for being here over the
last two weeks and delivering such a
wonderful series of lectures it's it's
very much an important part of our
intellectual activity here at Yale the
the Dwight Terry lectur ship is one of
the most prestigious lecture series and
so it's been a particular pleasure to
have you here I enjoyed today's lecture
enormously I love the concept of a scale
of Machiavellian behavior and and as as
as as a new Provost I'm I I am going I
am going to rush back to my office to
put different people in high Mac and low
Mac categories so so on on behalf of of
Yale I particularly want to present you
with a momento and remembrance of your
two weeks here in New Haven thank you
very
much